[Music]
CTL allows students to really develop in
their own directions because of the
freedoms of they're granted I don't know
exactly how many books I've read this
year
her first seminal work was the core of
my studies at Columbia University's
Teachers College
I'm Nancy Atwell and I'm the founder of
and a teacher at the Center for teaching
and learning these stories are so good
they will change your mind I never
wanted to be a teacher wasn't even going
to go to college nobody in my family had
gone to college mom said you know you
should just go to the local college and
then after four years I had a BA in
English and no idea what to do with it
so I stuck around and did student
teaching the first time I went into a
classroom I felt like I was home it was
where I was meant to be and I think the
same thing has happened to my daughter
she feels that same sense of belonging I
felt so strongly about what was
happening in my classroom and what my
kids were capable of that it seemed
imperative to tell other teachers
exactly what my methods were so that
they could adopt those methods and their
kids would have the same opportunities
so I decided that I would create a place
where I could teach children and
teachers at the same time 25 years worth
of the 40 to 50 teachers a year and I
think that the the impact of the school
sends these amazing ripple effects out
into the world I've been using Nancy's
techniques as the basis of what I do in
the classroom even in East Harlem in
Astoria in New York in public schools it
works anywhere in any setting
what's essential about the way I teach
is choice children choose what they're
going to read and they choose what
they're going to write about I can't say
enough about the power of reading the
vicarious experiences that children have
the people they need the ideas they have
it's just very dull I think that stories
are the English teachers superhero power
and I can illustrate that with a story
about a boy I taught a few years ago he
said he'd never read a book
I watched my teach himself how to read
he read 36 books as an eighth grader and
in every instance it was because he
wanted to know what happened Thanks
he couldn't wait for me to shut up so we
could get to the independent reading
it's not possible for children any
longer to just understand their own
communities they need to understand the
world and they need to have vicarious
experiences of it and they need to have
empathy for the range of experience that
exists beyond their own borders we've
operated on a number of fronts we
celebrate every kind of religious or
ethnic holiday but then there are the
books there's such rich children's
literature about children who live all
over the world
to me I think that my mom proves that
you can to teach the way that you want
to the way that you believe is right and
is best for kids that is her greatest
legacy she's showing other teachers that
they can do that
in all the years that I was traveling on
weekends to give speeches
I told whoever was introducing me you
know really we don't need to talk about
the number of books and the awards and
just tell these people I taught
yesterday that's really what they need
to hear that I was in the classroom
yesterday like they were
[Music]
you